all right everyone
thank you we're on page um 36 of
our 35 onwards on our
folders there's no um
uh reports that i
picked up so pat and you've
circulated some fees and charges
so um kenny do you want to take us
through your budget thank you
welcome by the way thank you
i've got a quite a few key points but
i'll try and keep them as brief as i can
the recycling rate um i'm proposing to
hold the recycling rate steady
next year put up the rubbish collection
rates going to the increase in waste
levy
because that impacts on the rubbish
disposal charges
and also proposing to increase organic
spins by two dollars a bin
as signaled in the previous long-term
plan and that's because of cpi increases
to disposal charges
also proposing the rubbish bag charges
increased to 3.20 per bag
and that's a mix of levy increase in cpi
increases and bad costs
also the bin delivery charges will go up
50 cents
to 18 with a maximum charge of 36
dollars for two or three bins
and because the rubbish rate will be
going up
the rate will be going up for the
rubbish bins the fifa rubbish bin swap
up will increase to 31.75 from 30
i've made an additional fifty thousand
dollar budget around
allowance uh to continue with the
maintenance
maintenance level of recycling bin
audits
um note that this may need to be
increased and that will depend on
how well further audits which have yet
to be approved by council
that we propose these to get done to
improve the striking quality
over the next few months and staff would
bring a report to council to seek
additional budget in the 21 22 year for
that
um should that prove to be necessary so
hopefully that will be coming through at
deliberations
i'm recommending that 70
600 of the increased levy funding we're
expecting
will come to the budget to help fund the
audits and recycling processing costs
and that the 200 000 per annum transfer
from the general rate to be dropped
stopped a year early
that does not apply for next year
it should be noted the total increase in
rates between this and next year and the
curbside collection budget sheet is
caused by the continual growth
in the district and it's resulted in
more bins being in service than we
projected
for the current year um
i'm expecting there will be over 1600
more recycling bins and 1 600 more
rubbish bins
in circulation and 530 odd more organic
spins
at the start of 21 22 than we had
projected for 2021
so although the rate is
fairly minor the overall rate increase
because of that
is quite substantial
in the waste minimisation account i'm
proposing
that the general rate to be increased
from 20 000 to 21
700 to fund more council overheads and
service recovery charges
and an increase in litter management
costs
the increase in landfill levy will start
providing additional funds at the end of
the first quarter
and the census population numbers will
also should also result in a slight
increase to our district
and our forecast will receive an
additional 143 thousand dollars
in the coming year
i'm proposing that placeholder budget
allowances be made
for an additional ten thousand dollars
for both the canterbury waste joint
committee
and for rural recycling facility
operations and
note that council approval still needs
to be sought for
any the provision of rural recycling
services
and we've made some decreases to some
operational budgets that partially
offset these proposed increased
budgetary allowances
i note on page
[Music]
is it 3.2 um
i haven't got a date for the rural
recycling infrastructure
that should read from 21 22
to 25 26
so it'll be a five-year program of
rolling out new
recycling facilities to um five
new rural areas it's just the bait uh
near the bottom of page 43 on your
agenda
and and that's just a budgetary
allowance for that and
and as i said that will require um
council approval to proceed with that
project
finally in the disposal account i'm
proposing to make no change to the
general rate
that the gate charges for green waste be
retained at the current charge
the general waste will rubbish charge be
increased by 11.50 per tonne which is
for the levy increase only
we can absorb um the ets
increases that trans waste are proposing
in any cpi increases
for the contract owing to cost savings
from new contract division activities
within that budget
proposing that clean fill and hard fill
be increased by six dollars a tonne
to a hundred dollars a ton and buy and
that's the
clean phil hartfield disposed of it the
transfer station
and by four cubic metres uh
for cleanful and hardful being dropped
off directly to sutherland's pit
and we're also putting the charge up for
expanded polystyrene foam that is not
recyclable by 11.50 per tonne which is
the waste living
but that doesn't have impact impact on
non-recyclable
minimum charges and per unit charges
and we've also got three new charges for
three different types of tyres
i apologize for some regrettable errors
in the gate charge tables on 24 pages 45
to 48
and i have circulated highlighted and
read what those charges
should read and they're the figures that
i've used in my budgets
but unfortunately i hadn't transposed
that into the budget commentary
the overall income to the account is
estimated to increase by over 431
000 and that's increases in tonnages as
well as the gate charge increases
and that includes some income through
the gain in pain share agreement in the
new contract
total operating expenditure will
increase by around about 254
000 and that's by a number of
new budgetary allowances for what asset
management improvements and rates
remissions and refunds
and increases to some other budgets
amounting to about fifteen thousand
dollars extra
but the majority of the increases and
costs are related to
the increase in tonnage and the increase
in disposal charges
we've also reduced budgets for closed
landfill maintenance and monitoring
by around about seven thousand i'm also
recommending that about seventy thousand
six hundred
of the increased level funding be used
to help fund hazardous waste and
recycling management
and transportation costs at south brook
and oxford
and i'm happy to take questions thanks
kitty
um i might just start that off my
other colleagues but um the adequacy of
south brock
um in general you know i've used it a
few times over
lately it's always busy when i've been
down there i know it's just post
christmas so it was a pretty busy period
in the lead up but there was just very
a lot of people there this is a 10-year
budget
we are we looking at you know the
adequacy
of um or whether whether the path is
sorry in the recycling area is adequate
in terms of its size
i know you're talking about an education
area possible extension but
in general is is it adequate what we've
got
we're having the project delivery unit
look at
a site development plan this year
and we have scheduled design
and construction of the recycling area
and reuse area
upgrade and expansion so designed next
year and
expansion in the following year and then
the
pit changes have been pushed out a
couple of years
just to try and help level the rates
rises but that can always be brought
forward if it's
going to be important enough so peter
you are doing that work
okay and you'll report back to us on
that in terms of the
i've already mentioned this to you a
couple of times sorry
yes no yes um
mentioned to you a couple of times about
the condition down there
have we got enough money in the budget
to make sure that
in with the contract that the place is
being well maintained because i
my observation is it's not at the moment
that is something we're dealing with
with waste management they have given us
a price in their contract for site
maintenance um and we'll have to talk to
them about the fact that they're not
living up to our expectations and how
that is best managed
we've got we've got money in our budgets
for maintenance
painting all those sort of things of the
in general condition
apart from the land which is just saying
you're going to deal with but there's
money in there to make sure that it's
kept
looking sharp we've got maintenance
budget for the work that we see is
necessary and they have
in in the contract operations
um budgets they're
mowing and weeding etc um should be
covered in that
maybe at our next working party or unr
bring us a bit of an update
on that thank you i'm i'm intending to
bring a report
to the soldered and hazardous waste
working party about the pathway forward
for
for forward maintenance on that any
other questions
council vote
um kitty reports on the street are that
audited areas are improving but not
altered areas
aren't and we're still receiving very
high levels of recycling contamination
are you confident that the money you've
gotten here is going to be sufficient to
actually make sure that we crack down
on on the non-elected areas to try and
get to a level that's satisfactory
the maintenance budget i'd allowed for
was to
keep recycling at the levels that we got
to after the audits
i will be bringing a report to council
to to increase the budget for auditing
in this current year
and i may have to increase the budget um
and next year if if we have to carry on
the budgets into
2122 so we may have more budget
allowance
we've we've reached 50 um acceptance
um which is quite a distinct improvement
over what it used to be
but there's a long way to go
okay any other questions
just carrying on from that uh kitty um
this is this is everybody's having to
pay for a few that are
not adhering to the thing is there any
way that you can charge them
extra for the um service that they
do not want of course but are having to
you've having to do it
there's no way we can charge extra but
we will remove bins if people do not
um comply um two bins have been removed
i believe there's another couple
that are going to be uplifted and
there's i think last time i checked
there were nine on the removable
list to be removed next time they put
them out the collection but they haven't
been
so at least those bins haven't been
presented and haven't been contaminating
the
recycling stream
okay no further questions so is there
any general
remarks we'd like to make
we do kitty um thank you very much
uh when you're talking about the next
waste meeting and
and i'm just wondering if perhaps we
could go and have a look at the with the
whole area down at
southbrook as a collective
i have intent well
i'm waiting for the pdu to bring back
the plan which i'll discuss with you and
at that point it might be appropriate
for us to go here on site and just sort
of have a look and
and see what when tend to go where or
what could go where
yeah the other thing i just like to make
a comment is i did
take some doubt down to the reuse shop
and i was actually really impressed with
the service there
and the you know the staff
thank you i just just like to add to
that um
staff actually
particularly helpful
and we're now the way that i observed
with other people there to make sure
that they were doing the right thing
you've had a particularly trying year
with everything that's been going on
and seeing the mixed messaging that the
city didn't help with
um and i think the waste tool that's
certainly been a lot of challenge in
that space but it also
be interested to see whether it's
reporting on it at some stage and how
that's going
in general so because obviously we put a
lot of effort into trying to get people
to do the right thing again so
hopefully that's continuing but the
audit's been a a really
an essential part of that so thanks um
to you my niece and team
i think you're doing a really good job
in this space and look forward to those
updates that we talked about on
southbrook and i'm not in touch with
what's happening in oxford apart from
what
is put there but if we are having a look
at south it might be a good opportunity
to look at
um oxford it's some stage as well
um just to gain a bit of a better
picture of how things are going up there
thank you so you're done
that's it thank you so
uh next is water
uh it's a colin kelly
thanks kitty
all right so the page is 59 on and the
papers
we've got we've
[Music]
there is a report referred from unr 4.4
is that yeah
um should we deal with that first um we
got a 4.4
so i'll just get the right paper sorry
four point four sets tab six in our
pages so
you wanna cover that first and then
we'll go into the pages
thank you thank you so um yeah i'll just
quickly talk through the report
under item 4.4 which is under pegasus
filter send
so this has been reported to the
utilities and writing committee and has
been recommended by that committee
before so i won't
go into too much detail but um just to
give a quick overview so the
um in general the pegasus uh manganese
removal filter has performed
very well since conversion to a
biological filter we did see
when we added the wooden flows into it
as well
that there was some loss of performance
during peak
flow conditions and because of this we
topped up
the sand in one filter which we had
noticed was lower than expected
with a higher or a different grade of
sand and that
improved performance so that's been good
however through the study into that
performance we did note that as flows
increase further with growth which
there is a lot of growth forecast for
that scheme
we we are expecting that the performance
will drop away
if we leave the sand as it is
which would lead to a risk of an
increased risk of biofilm growth
on the scheme so to address this
we're recommending that the sand be
completely replaced with a coarser grain
of sand so rather than 0.6 millimeter
be 0.9 which doesn't sound significant
but in terms of
it's the amount of manganese you can
remove per cubic meter of sand it is
actually
does um increase the capacity for
by manganese removal quite a lot and in
turn that
removes the expected biofilm growth
rates
um the recommendation is to put in a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars of
budget in year three
of the long term plan period to do this
um
as this is related to growth it would be
the costs would be covered through
contributions from the ravenswood
development so
we're not forecasting a rating impact as
a result of that
um given it would be a growth project so
happy to take any questions on that
okay thank you any questions counselor
thank you and just um colin just want to
know what do you do with the used
sand with the manganese and things like
that
can it just go back onto the ground or
do you have to
ah that's a good question and i think
that's
um although the report into it is very
thorough
that hasn't actually been considered it
would be um
it's not contaminated sand or anything
that's it's
sterile enough to have drinking water
pass through it so it would um
there's bound to be a use for it we
would have to work with the contractor
and what their use would be
but it yeah it wouldn't be a waste i'm
sure there would be useful thank you
any further questions there's a
recommendation
to layering that provision somewhat
prepared to move moved by
council violence second council banking
council
yes when this report was presented to
unr
it was completely sensible and
very very important that we do treat the
manganese i've seen the results when we
don't and the complaints that we get
from the public
so i think it's a very very sensible
thing to do
and fully in support of this
recommendation
any further any further speakers
council duty at unr we just um
thank gary very much for all this
evidence put into it i just want that to
be
relayed again because um his his effort
is incredible
thank you thank you
what the recommendation so shown all
those in favor aye
contrary to that carried so we now come
to the
budget papers against page 59.
do you have any thing you wish to
highlight here colin yeah i've got a few
points to talk
through um so i'll i'll try to keep it
brief because i know you've got a lot to
work through but
um i'll start with a little bit of
um the background into the setting of
the budgets
talk through the rating impact uh the
key issues
and then just summarize the o m and
capital budgets
um and then take questions so in terms
of background
uh there's three key components to the
capital budgets
and uh i thought i'd give a little bit
of
uh an overview of how we came up with
those budgets so there's
the three components of renewals growth
and level of service
uh the renewals work the the main work
we've done
since the last long-term plan as we've
updated our renewals model
with better a better understanding of
base life of the
pipe assets which are the by far the
highest value asset class we have so we
now understand
the performance of those assets better
and we've also got a new valuation
report so the expected life and
evaluation data
basically gives us our renewals program
so we've got a greater degree of
confidence now and when we should be
replacing pipes and how much we expect
it to cost
and renewals makes up about 17 million
dollars of the 10-year budget
growth is another significant area so
growth forecasts we take the
um the projections from planning we feed
that into the
uh reticulation model which is um run by
our network planning team and out of
that they build in that growth
and recommend the what assets will need
over the 10-year
period to to accommodate that growth
so that makes up the growth component of
the budgets there's about
12.4 million dollars worth of growth
projects within the first 10 years
and then the final capital budget type
is level of service
which is 12 million dollars worth of
level of service projects and that's
essentially where we're not
um meeting a current level of service
through our performance measure
reporting or where we
are aware of um something like drinking
water standards changing that we
identify we need new level of service
projects to accommodate that so that
might be a new treatment equipment or
we're not meeting
our criteria in terms of the amount of
resilience or redundancy we need
that could also be a trigger for a level
of service project
so collectively those are the three
broad budget types and how we
go about setting them
in terms of rating impact this is
presented in
table 1 so you can see that there are
some
[Music]
some schemes with increases in some with
decreases um i and there's notes on
the reasons for that i thought i
wouldn't go through them all because
there's
um 14 schemes so i think i'll just take
questions
on particular schemes at the end
the key issues i was going to talk
through
[Music]
one of the major ones is that the
pending changes to standards and
regulation of drinking water so this
right at the end of last year we had
draft drinking water standards released
for
um for information and they'll be
formally released
around may we expect this year um
so that's definitely going to trigger
some a lot of change within the drinking
water space and we also have a new
drinking water regulator
expected to be established by the water
services bill
um around the middle of this year so
both of those things
um we know will cause change and we've
tried to make provision for
for how we'll deal with that change but
um
[Music]
there is still some level of uncertainty
because it includes
things like exemptions and and it's
still got
it's not completely black and white that
we can definitively say these budgets
will exactly deal with these standards
we
we think they're the best um
effort we have been able to make with
the information we have but there's
still some uncertainty in terms of
exactly how
what the final standards will look like
and how they'll be interpreted and how
they'll be regulated so um i wanted to
highlight that
that we have tried to deal with that
uncertainty but there is still some
residual risk
um another key issue
throughout um or
something we've tried to deal with
throughout the budgets is the need to
keep up with required source and storage
upgrades
so these could be required either for
resiliency
or for accommodating growth or a
combination of both
um and a large number of schemes have
one or the other required in the coming
10 years so an example of a resiliency
um type source or storage upgrade
project is at mandible where we've got
one primary well
and last year we experienced an issue
with that well which meant
uh during the time when we were
replacing that welcome we were down to
back up wells only and
and therefore didn't achieve compliance
so we've
we've always signaled the need for a
backup well at mandeville so that's
that's a resiliency type project it's
not because of growth it's just because
we need redundancy for when these kind
of issues happen
and then in terms of growth there's
other schemes that need projects for
growth
uh with rank euro being a good example
where
a second reservoir south belt is
required
as well as another uh sixth well after
the fifth well didn't achieve the yield
we were hoping for
um and there's other similar projects as
well on other schemes
um another key point
to talk through a little is the stimulus
funding
so this has also been reported and
discussed quite a lot um
by the council and is well underway uh
in terms of delivery but
um one thing that we have been looking
into and has been considered
is the equity and fairness between
schemes
and in particular um there's been
discussions with this council before
between the relationship between points
road summer hill and west eastern so i
thought i'd
draw attention a little bit to those
three schemes so
um there there's been recommendations
about a contribution from points road to
the other two schemes
and as a condition of joining and
uh we now have the uh calculated rating
impact
of that contribution alongside all the
other
um things that are going on within those
three schemes so
points rate is forecast to increase by
about 50
across two years and then uh summer hill
decreased by nine percent in the first
year and we see them by three percent
so those decreases are not
purely a result of the contribution um
there's been some other
or one other change that in particular
has benefited summer hill
with the uh interest rate uh reduction
and someone who having a large loan that
that that's meant that somehow we're
seeing the biggest benefit of a
reduction in issue and an interest rate
but also the contribution from points
road
has helped that as well um
so i think um it is seeing those three
schemes rates moving closer together
um the
[Music]
i i'll probably just one more thing i
was going to mention
is the um there's a table showing the
overall capital spend
towards the end which i thought i would
point out so
that is my table for
um and that shows the the projected
capital spend
over the next 10 years um
the the top row is what was previous in
the last annual plan
um and then the second row is what we're
now proposing
and we and it also shows the differences
so
if you look to the far right you can see
we were previously projecting 44 million
dollars worth of
capital works over the 10 years and
we're now
um proposing 41 million so we have found
some moderate savings of about 2.8
million
or six percent reduction in the capital
program
as well as some ups and downs on a year
by year basis so
a key reason for the reduction overall
is the renewals expenditure we had last
time had about 19
19 million dollars worth of renewals
budgets now we have about 16
so that's really the difference and that
that's
generally a result of our renewals model
being
re-run with um updated
asset-based lives and valuation
um data and
and yeah acros there are lots of ups and
downs on different pipe sizes and types
and everything else
but um there have
there have been some pipe types where
we've realized they actually have a
greater
or can achieve a greater life than we'd
previously assumed and
because of that the the amount of
renewals we need in the first 10 years
isn't quite as much as previously so
that has allowed
some saving um
probably the only other significant
change as i was going to talk through is
just some
shifting of budgets within the initial
years which has kind of spread out
the load so it was previously quite
front loaded with year one having a
large number of 9.5 million and then
some three million dollar
years after that and now the numbers are
more
similar um with some of that year one
stuff
being deferred and that is mainly
um uv projects being pushed out from
year one because we still don't have the
confidence to look at
draft standards and say definitely
definitely what we're going to
build because it it still depends on
exemptions for coronation and
um yeah so that it's mainly due to us
not having the certainty to
to start construction of those works yet
um
has been the key driver for that
um so finally i'll just talk through the
recommendations and i think
a slightly updated set has been
circulated so the first recommendation
is
to adopt the budgets as recommended and
then there's also recommendations passed
on
from the utilities and wroting committee
in terms of changes to the
um level of service performance measures
um which so these were all recommended
by utilities and wrote in committee for
inclusion in the draft long term plan
so this is really just to confirm
that that's what we're recommending goes
into the draft long-term plan
um you might recall that
in general the changes were um
for ease of reporting or um to bring
things up with uh the way some measures
are currently measured so it's not
to change an actual level of service the
public will notice a difference in but
more
just to make our reporting more
meaningful um
so i wasn't going to talk through them
anymore seeing as they've been
previously reported and recommended
so happy to take any questions
your table 6 which is on my page 71
in the in the folder um
when um you've got charges there for um
filling tanks why why is it only monday
to thursday what's wrong with a friday
it's because it's a two-day job one day
we take the restrictor out
and that the tank starts to fill and the
next day we come back and put the
restrictor in
so if someone asks for a quick fill on a
thursday we go there on the thursday we
come back on the friday if they ask for
it on the friday we go on the friday
come back on the saturday so it becomes
a weekend
job so why can't you do it on the friday
we we could do that and we sometimes do
um if the scheme can handle it that
means they
it's better for the resident because
they get more water at full flow
but there might be times like this time
of year when we might not be comfortable
having
giving someone a full flow for um
you know friday saturday sunday and part
of monday so we don't promise it
but we sometimes do it as a um when we
can yeah well i mean
having been on the receiving end of a
quick film
um and you know
you need it when you need it yes um i
would appreciate that in fact
there was a a full weekday service
and you did look it when you come back
and put the restrictor in
and on the monday if you're in fact it
was a friday yeah
we yeah like i said we do that where we
can
but we i guess we don't
promise that yeah uh as a rule it would
almost incentivize people to get them on
the friday because
you get more more water for your money
well it's not more water it's just it's
filling up faster yeah i mean yeah
you've got to use it i mean
thank you
thank you now just uh copper's increases
at 13
and one of the one of the uh things
that's
marked down here is an increased
sampling costs is that something of the
source
for the water that's going to the rest
of the district and if that is the case
because the are the kuiper scheme paying
for the sampling
for what's going out past its own scheme
no
uh the is definitely something only if
kai poi great players pay for something
of water that's delivered to kyogre
residents and
rangiora pays for water that's delivered
to
rancho residents so why is that in the
commentary particularly
um pointed out when it's not in the
other commentaries because surely if
they've
got an increased yeah why do the others
not
yeah um the we had increased the
sampling frequency
for particularly for untreated schemes
and the larger untreated schemes because
um
the standards actually don't require a
whole lot for
secure source water um and it's really
not just doing the minimum isn't isn't
seen as enough by anyone in in the
industry and it doesn't allow us to
respond very well if
if we did get in a bad result there
would be a big gap so
um that's just the reason in general to
increase in terms of why
one scheme and not the other rank euro
has had sampling cost increases but
it's just um it must have
not it must have been balanced out by
some other savings within the scheme
that it hasn't overall
resulted in a rates rise so that's just
um
focus mentioned as that's part of the
one cost that has increased on the
scheme that's
resulted in a net cost increase but
that's probably not the biggest
reason why um there had been
in kaiapoi in the previous year some
discounting of the rates so i think it
was another annual plan
cycle there'd been similar kind of rates
increase forecast and it had been then
tried to smooth out to phase it and so
there had been discounting of the rates
the previous year
and that's enough and that's now been
removed because you can't discount the
rates every year because essentially
but just just for no not for here i'm
not yeah
but i'd like to see some more
information on that because i'm afraid i
don't
really get that equation so you know for
the future not for now but yeah i'd
really like to see the differences there
and why it's mentioned in one commentary
when everybody said the same i mean i
don't get our balance out on something
but
yeah so i'd like some more information
on that in the future
yeah um with what the government's
signaling with um
fluoride have we made any what's cost
but we have to fluoride all of our
schemes
have we got a no i mean fluoride
what's the um minister has indicated the
district health board may be in charge
of florida
nation now yeah we we yeah
councillor williams is right there's
been some very recent signals about that
when um we did get some advice on the
cost of fluoridate
a few years ago when the bill was first
introduced
and then the bill just sat there and
didn't seem to be going anywhere
at all so we haven't made budget
provision
to florida um the cost is significant i
don't have the number of my heat but
it's
well into the millions of dollars of
where to do every single scheme
um and it's only been the last couple of
days i've read that article that um the
health minister has been
saying that it is something he wants to
look into further but
there's a few steps away from where it
is now
to it actually becoming us fluoridating
any of our suppliers that would the bill
is written that it would
give our district households the ability
to make decisions regarding fluoridation
and then the district health board could
decide to instruct us to fluoridate
some or all of our supplies so the bill
would have to actually get passed and
then it would have to
you know have some kind of phase and
then the district health boards would
have to think about it and think what
supplies
are top priority and then it would and
then there'd be some time for us to
actually
do it so we yeah it is a
key something to monitor for the future
but i haven't allowed for it
right now
yes colin thank you very much for your
answers to my questions they've been
very very helpful
i just want to tease a couple of them
out a little bit more and particularly
in terms of communication with our
advisory groups which i think is of
critical importance
and the first one is gary mayer yeah
which is
um you've stated in this public document
that some unplanned costs occurred in
can you advise us what they were yeah
and why that hasn't gone through to the
advisory group
so that the main thing was the well pump
failed
and was replaced and um that
we have talked to the two um
the two key members of the advisory
group about that because they're also
the two neighbours to the well site and
we
we talked about as it was happening we
were telling them what was going on so
they're definitely well aware of
that happening um we just haven't had a
formal advisory group meeting
about that particular thing um so that
could be addressed
going forward that we could let
everybody know yep that would be great
yeah
yeah i appreciate your commentary that
it's similar to an old budget figure but
it's not similar to the the the rate and
the annual plan
so thank you um the the other ones
were summerhill and west earthen the
adding
of lines into their budgets from 21
22 for inspection servicing maintenance
valves now appreciate points road has
taken
the the line share your attention and
dealing with research in summerhill
but do you think it's appropriate to add
budget lines in this year without having
gone through that with the advisory
board could it be deferred another year
until that's been sorted uh so the
reason
um those budget lines are not new work
we're proposing on western summer hill
that we didn't used to do
we've always fixed valves when they
failed or checked restrictors
and that kind of thing and all that had
been picked up is
um in other budgets there was a certain
set of
um budget lines under articulation and
then that feeds through to water unit
job
costing codes and then it was slightly
inconsistent with west end of summer
hill
the wood unit did the same work on those
schemes but they didn't have as many gl
codes to charge to so they were charging
one type of work and lumping it with
another and just charging it to another
line
so we're not doing anything differently
it's just more to tidy up
so in that case shouldn't those lines
have gone down which they haven't
uh they yes i think um so
the budget's increased by those amounts
rather than gone yeah yeah and that's
because we
when we looked at past expenditure on
the other rows which had
um the two work types lumped together we
had
we've been over spending in past years
so it's
we're not um yeah we're one way or
another the budget's needed to
to increase whether it's increased by
one line by a lot
or introduce the second line and then
add a new charge so you're saying your
maintenance budget had doubled
and we then we see it in for example
from 1900 and adding on another 2000
yeah for that particular item because
it's not a lot of
it only takes a couple of jobs to to
spend that and it's
that it's this um issue with small
schemes it
yeah yeah it's it's very hard to
appreciate that so how are you going to
now communicate that
back to the louis certain summer hill
advisory group well it had been brought
up
at a meeting in the past and it was the
way it was explained was they would like
to go to in the past they had been
through every row of a budget and they
said that would be a good thing to do in
the future but they were
happy to just work on the points for
joining for now
get that project done and then but they
wanted to keep the group active and then
do that more
um you know once we took more business
as usual state then they can actually
just review overall how's the scheme
funded and that
so would it be possible for you to and
to actually communicate those increases
back to the group
yeah that's what will happen when we
when we get to that point of meeting
going through the budgets that's
being requested we'll do that thank you
yeah
i just no one else is just to say thank
you team
um excellent work you're right over on
top of
your particular projects and all the
schemes and
we've all talked pre-christmas as we've
worked into the stimulus just
how appreciative we are of all the work
that's been done in the meetings
council williams and i've been to the
two huey ones
um in the one i would end last night i
understand
if i'm correct um that we um 21 out of
21 have signed up the other
side is that right yeah definitely 20
and we're working on the 21st so i don't
know if we've got that so first yet but
which prints well with the um to a kiwi
um but feedback we got was really
positive actually at those particular
exercises so
really good information that was there
so um it was an excellent presentation
so thanks for all the work you're doing
appreciate it thank you all right well
they're up to waste water
let's welcome kevin to the table
thanks colin
it's page
after you run page 124 everyone
[Applause]
you've got no other reports in here that
i've picked up so
give us a bit of an overview and then
there may be some questions
thanksgiving yeah i'll run through a
brief overview of the main points
of the commentary uh so in terms of
rates
uh generally the rates have decreased
um east districts and oxfords have
decreased for what was forecast um
obviously with food inside a low mainly
the rates are changing with the
connection to the eastern district sure
scheme
that's going to happen over the next 12
months
the main points um
[Music]
to consider in general is obviously uh
in terms of stimulus projects
um this not this
this report cover this commentary covers
any
funding that fixed rates the level
service and
growth components which doesn't cover
the government
funding that's for the labor and leave
inside into away
kaiba kyboy capacity upgrade is a key
point to note
as part of this so um in the last ltp
uh we would have been in construction
now for the capacity upgrade but we've
done
a lot of work in terms of modelling and
monitoring in the network
and we've identified
the main issue is in
existing areas that have high ioni
inflamed filtration into the network
so we looked at what would it cost
to convey those high flows in the
network
to provide the level of service that's
required the cost was quite substantial
so what we're
undertaking at the moment is to do more
investigation work to understand the
infiltrating
inflow over the next two years which is
where you'll see in the optics budgets
in kai poi we have um 140
000 next year 110 000 the following year
to
undertake further investigations the
purpose of that is to understand
um where the ioni is coming from and if
there is any opportunities to
reduce it at a at a lower cost
but also not in that obviously with the
shovel ready projects
there's a clear linkage between high
wastewater flows and
drainage so that's another reason why i
would like to
we've pushed the capital budgets out to
year five for the kaiapoi company
upgrade
so we get a better understanding where
to better spend that money
in addition to that is obviously krillin
street which is project which has also
been pushed out
um that's i'll see a catchment kai boy
so we're training the same we've done a
lot of work in kritlin street to
understand where the high flows are
coming
there's permanent monitors in the
cridlin street catchment
so during weather events we'll get a
better understanding
of where those high flows are coming
from and
the approach we're taking is it would
ideally like to target the source of the
high flows
as opposed to convey it out of cowboy
through the network
because it has downstream effects the
central ring or a
capacity upgrade um that's gonna
carry on through years one and four and
it'll be completed year from year four
that's on track the
most biggest change um similar to water
in terms of kpx is due the reduced
renewals budget which is
um as a result of our modelling in terms
of renewals
has reduced quite uh substantially
um if you do go to section 3.2 of the um
commentary you'll see a semi graph um
that was on the water so over 10 years
there's a 10p 10 decrease in
um the 2020 annual plan
uh capex over 10 years compared to the
proposed um
budget for the the cell tp that's driven
mostly by a reduction in renewal's
budget but also
there's 1.8 million set aside for
upgrading the touahe pump station
which has been removed with the upgrades
being untaken part of the stimulus
in terms of opex there's no major
changes apart from
kaipoi we have brought some budget
forward to for
further work and sludge removal but also
to uh investigate um undertake some
studies on
we've got quite a lot of sludge stored
in chi poi on site
so we want to um do analysis on that
that's large to understand what we can
use there for uh also
um i mentioned before a budget to
increase
um infiltration and inflow
investigations in the kaipal network
also um have an added budget for mission
control at kaiboy
uh which we trial at the moment and
seems to be having some success
so i've included twenty thousand dollars
in the quiet budget for that
in terms of um revenue charges we've
increased the trade waste
fees which they hadn't been changed for
quite some time so there's been a
moderate increase
in those charges you'll also notice that
we've added a
a a fee and therefore septage
charges which is when the new subject
facility at rangor is completed which
will be hopefully in quarter
the fourth quarter of uh year one
there's a fees in there to begin
charging for
receiving septage
just go to recommendations so including
the recommendations is
um the
approvals for earlier or service perform
measures which was a report um
to deliver to you and ah so i won't go
through the detail but um
the uh public won't notice any changes
it's just more how we how we report
um a little service um to to make it
more tidy and also bring us
more in line with our water so it's
there's some consistency
questions thanks kevin any questions
paul sorry castle williams philippine
council
the ocean outfall i can't see any budget
in there for
um looking at better treatment sources
and because we've had quite a few
complaints with um
water and without discharge we're
probably going to have to upgrade it
soon
there's no budget in there to see what
we can do to improve things here
should we be doing that asap
we are currently drafting up a plan for
consent renewal so
peter marx has undertaken that for us so
uh out of that plan we'll
develop some budgets when we go in the
next annual plan but that is on the
horizon to definitely look at
long term and we certainly are any
upgrades we're undertaking but we're
trying to
think you know what what's the
long-term potential constant conditions
so one of those examples is um well
wood in wastewater implant upgrade was
achievable 2025 we've noted that we can
push that out a bit further due to
the capacity of the plant and growth
predictions
so we're pushing as far as we can to get
that close to
the consent renewal the point there is
deferring where we can
capital investment until we know what
those future conditions are
just as nothing in this ten year we
can't wait till the
consent expires
so the work that gavin was talking about
that we're looking at scoping to work
out what budgets we actually need
they'll be
that work will be undertaken from
current asset management budgets
um our consent for the ocean out for
expires in 2038
so we really want to have a strategy
that's kicking off about
10 years prior to that so from about
2028 onwards
so we're really this long-term plan
period is about doing some
pre-feasibility work to start scoping
out budgets
and come 2024 34 long-term plan that's
where we will be actually putting
additional budgets uh relating to the
renewal of that consent
so um need to note that um there is
budget there any and
it's under renewals for uh oxford
consent renewal and also uh there should
be some
uh budget in there for the um
i think there's there's a consent also
in rangiora that's going to be requiring
you
i saw that i i just was concerned we're
probably going to have some objections
to
our consent for the ocean outfall and it
would
probably look nice that we're trying to
do something now i'm thinking about it
at all
yep okay thank you
uh sorry it's council stewart thank you
yes thank you um on page 136 we
i've presumed this is the change in the
trade waste
um charges um can you um
so is the whoever's bringing in the
trade waste are they required to
test these parameters so you can charge
in that way and how much trade waste
do we get because i always thought that
we were
our plants were really designed for
domestic served rather than travis
we currently have um three trade waste
agreements
and it's uh predominantly in kai boy
and with those those three
we do undertake sampling uh once a month
so obviously um there's these costs
taken undertaken sampling so it's done
monthly
they also have flow meters
attached to to the discharge so we know
the quantities
now those these charges won't
immediately apply to those three
the agreements uh our two of them are
will expire later this year
so when they are up for renewal these
these
charges will be applied but obviously we
have to talk to them
um anyone we we do their instances we
will have minor trade wastes
discharges we wouldn't go and
potentially
monitor them and charge them so there's
a balance where it becomes economical
to get enough information such as us to
better charge them
council stuart can you use your
microphone we're the three
that we've got trade waste howlers
foundation foods
and riverside the camping ground
yeah okay any further questions thank
you
um any general remarks anyone would like
to add
just same applies is what i said to
colin before gavin appreciate
what you and your team are doing in
actual fact i was talking about
wastewater in the end of that
last one but uh in terms of the upgrades
and fun side and two of you but
very good presentations i'm sure you
inquiredly took that
just with colin sitting there i just
missed the um
subject heading but uh those
consultations have gone really well
and um you and the team are doing a
fantastic job we really appreciate it
thank you
all right so
we're now at drainage um so
it's under kelly so it's page
244.
so any items you'd like to summarise
there kelly cross
and the budget papers uh yes i'll just
cover the key issues to consider so
shove already you'll be well aware of so
that's predominantly having a rating
impact
on kai poi urban in years two
three and four uh one thing that was
pointed out
in terms of questions from
councillor barnett was that the kaipoy
urban rate
which is currently 305 is shown going
down to 295
um and then increasing in year two so
um what i suggest we do there is either
hold it at its current rate or smooth it
so it doesn't actually drop then
increase
um the second point is loan repayments
and
sorry just jumping back to that last
point i believe that's something that
finance can do as part of their
finalization of the budgets
um loan repayments so there has been an
increase in the ring euro
urban account and that has been really
due to
the south brook development contribution
so when that was set up
uh quite a few years ago now there were
two parts for it one was for
existing properties within that a south
brook industrial area
and the other was for development and
what appears has happened is that
the loan part of the
existing properties was actually set up
within the development contribution
but it was never the loan repayments
were never coming off the
rangi or a urban account so
they've effectively had a period of time
where they haven't been making those
loan repayments
um that's now been identified and the
um we've included the loan repayments
kicking off and that's actually
increased the amount we need to rate
from
ringy or urban by 72 000 per year and
that is one of the main reasons that
their rates have
increased by about 20 percent
uh cost rural drainage also a loan
repayment and that's because the account
is in deficit by twenty six thousand
dollars
um and to actually pay that loan
off is actually having quite a
significant impact on the cost scheme
you'll note that it's increasing by
about 50
drainage maintenance budgets so the we
are increasing one which is central
rural
by 15 last year we increased it by
10 percent but we're continually
spending a lot on maintenance in that
area this is something that's been
discussed with the advisory group and
they are supportive
of the um the rates being increased to
to cover the maintenance works being
undertaken um just under
overhead's insurance in public education
there's some general notes about
other increases one thing that's worth
noting is
in terms of our education budgets we
reduce them by
50 following covert 19 for the
2021 financial year we've continued that
on at the
lower rates within the long-term plan as
a
cost-saving measure
going through the next table there's
four that i just wanted to highlight
quickly
so the water zone work is having a 29
increase and that's because we have
changed how we
are treating the what was referred to as
minor capital works under that budget it
was set up originally for three years
and it was loan funded we're now
continuing it on
as a ongoing annual payment which
effectively means we need to treat it as
operational expenditure because we need
to recover those costs
in any one year so while we haven't
increased
the budget we've changed how we're
funding it rather than loan funding it's
been
charged for one financial year so that's
the reason for the thirty percent
increase here uh rangiora urban i've
already talked about the increase
there coastal urban has an increase
uh predominantly due to new
stormwater management areas that are
coming online um
so they get constructed we need to
maintain and operate them
yet the full development hasn't come out
to
be extended so we don't have the rate
payers
um coming through so that that again was
a question from
councillor barnett about whether uh that
is fair
and equitable for effectively existing
rate payers to be
funding the maintenance of
new infrastructure i can definitely see
that side of it
but equally the new people that are
coming online they are actually going to
be paying for
upgrades in the future to for the
existing
areas to comply with higher quality
standards as well so
i think it's in the category of you know
you never can
have a perfectly fair system um there's
going to be swings and roundabouts in
terms of
um you know who pays for what uh one
thing i did have a look at for
the coastal urban was the over the long
term plan period the rates continue to
increase so
even though it's not the situation that
we're spending a lot now
we get more growth and then the rates
drop back down so
it does reflect that you know there are
other projects level of
service related that will be being paid
for by both
existing and new properties and the
final one down there is cast which i've
already
talked about that has quite a
significant increase in rates
the capital works program over the 10
years
actually has changed quite significantly
and i've listed out the
projects that have been revised and also
the projects with
new budgets i'm happy to take any
questions on any of those projects but
the
key thing there is while we've had all
these changes
the net effect is still the same we're
still spending about
20 40 million dollars over the 10 years
period so
we were brought in a new specific
project we've actually
um dropped out another project so
particularly for some of the uh
quality projects we actually had lump
sum holding budgets that would peeled
out some of that budget from
to make sure there's no net increase
over the
um 10 years similar to
water and wastewater there are also
a level of service changes that were in
that report to unr
so i'm assuming that everyone has seen
those recommendations i've got
paper copies here if anybody hasn't seen
those
revised recommendations and the final
thing from me before taking
questions uh there was a query from the
roading budgets this morning regarding
the
handrails on dudley drain that are well
overdue to be
painted so we will look at scoping that
work
in terms of budget needs we believe we
can
address that via existing budgets we
have the kaiapoi
minus stormwater improvement budgets
which is about thirty thousand dollars
each year
um and it may even be that there is
budget available within the current
financial year to be able to arrange
that to be done so we will
um put that on the list of projects to
address
everybody take any questions did you say
you had some revised
papers the energy just in case perhaps
if you've got the me to circulate them
might as well see them yes uh council
duty
thank you kelly just a wee query please
on page 251 with oxford urban that
you're decreasing that
by 8k um
i'm just wondering why you're doing that
when there's work
work still to be done that that put a
seat in kitty just to help
with some of the 251 here
i'm just wondering why you're decreasing
it when it might be better just to leave
it sitting in there to help with other
flooding issues
i'll just flick to the um
to the sheet
so we we're still actually holding the
um
we're still actually holding all of the
maintenance budgets the same so in term
from an expenditure point of view
we're effectively saying that um when
it's
looked at in terms of the account
balance we don't actually need to
collect those rates
so we we're not reducing um
any of the uh expenditure
so your question is can we still hold it
at
the um previous amount
yes
uh i guess we could do but looking at it
from an account balance perspective
there's not a requirement to
but i just thought that would help
towards
wouldn't that help towards future work
that needs to be done
uh well what it would do would actually
mean that if there are
expenditure not currently predicted
within here it would mean the accounts
in a much healthier position
for any unexpected expenditure yeah i'd
rather
my my thoughts and it's just for you to
think about was i'd rather have a
smoothing thing going across
than than ups and downs
okay yep and i believe we could do that
similar to the kaiapoi urban effectively
manage it as part of the smoothing
exercise yeah
so i had counselor redmond followed by
council stuart
thanks kelly on page our page
254 mansfield park
secondary flow improvements
that now seems to include kiln place
it was my recollection that kiln place
was going to have improvements
either this year or next year
um given the extreme weather events
we're now having
with heavy rainfall and the likelihood
of flooding
um is this something that should be put
out to year five
when i thought it was going to be this
year or next year
so the investigation we've undertaken on
kiln place
so we do have budget this year and next
financial year and it's still
planned to spend that money um what
we're looking at doing
in the library report coming to unr on
this is
actually doing works to improve the
inlet capacity so increasing the sump
capacity at kiln place
we had originally intended that
we would be able to
improve the secondary flow within kiln
place
so that was potentially diverting water
into
um isaac is it newton place or
isaac wilson place thank you
and or potentially through um the
reserve
into cannon stack uh place uh and up to
the kaikanui street so the investigation
work that we've undertaken
has identified that that is not feasible
so we're still planning to proceed with
the first phase which is in
improving the inlet capacity but what
we've actually identified is that
kiln place is actually the low point for
secondary flow
from that whole mounds field park
development
so we actually need to look at a more
strategic
solution for it and it's not an easy fix
so we're still proceeding with phase one
of the kiln street project
but i've put this additional budget in
acknowledging that we've got a
secondary flow issue that we need to
take more of a strategic
catchment approach to address
okay uh carson stewart
thank you the east belt to cam river
connection
um proposal we're about to see proposing
to go into the headwaters of the camera
with that um
so that is is part of the north east
rangiora development area and that
connection
would be along a potential
extension of a road from kear street and
east belt so at the southern end of the
high school block that ex
extends in an easterly direction exactly
where it would connect into the hebrew
waters of the
the cam river is still to be determined
but it's probably effectively
um if you're familiar with that area
where they that homestead
is just to the east of the um
high school block not on gulf lakes
right
no further back no no closer
uh more closer to the boundary of the
high school block
just some very nice springs up there
that we don't want
still moving okay no matter how nice but
the second
the second question is you've got
um a box drain
improvements in wood end and then you
refer to box strain
on page 256 and you're talking about
oxford is there two boxed drains or is
that flannigan's dream
so 255 box drain improvements
in wood end to about a polluter um
pollutant trap
because then yeah that one and then on
the next page 256
you talk about box drain again
and you're talking the commentaries
about oxford is is that flanagan's or is
that another box correct
that that should say um flanigan's drain
that's an
error within the table itself
okay yeah thank you
thanks council stewart uh casablanca
thanks um kelly and jared for answering
all my questions so well
i've just got one i just wanted to tease
that a little bit more
and it's actually question for jared and
it's a strategic question of
all of our infrastructure when we're
adding on subdivisions to smaller
settlements
and for example in this case it's
coastal urban where we've got
ravenswood and two woods subdivisions
are now increasing the rates
on current um ratepayers um on quite a
small
ratepayer base and those areas haven't
been built yet so we can't collect
rates on the people who are there that's
happening with upgrade to
pump stations it happens with in the
previous budget
um are we looking at a more equitable
way to manage the optics of that going
forward
when it's on small like it's running or
a kai po it doesn't
hardly make a dent but when it's a small
subdivision if we had a subdivision at
swananoa or mandeville how
can we make that equitable when some of
those subdivisions are taking a long
time to develop so
that is a really good question and it
does apply across all
of three waters drainage in particular
is a little bit different so generally
as a rule when we add on more rate
payers to a scheme it actually
the benefits that generally outweigh the
costs so you get more
you do get more costs with the new
assets that are being
supplied to the scheme but you do
you get more rate payers and generally
the economies of scale come into effect
particularly when we're getting gifted
assets um and you would have seen in the
modelling that we
jeff presented this morning a lot of
those uh
long life assets that we get brand new
um
the way we managed to fund the
replacement of of those that really
helps us by
putting that wave way way so on the
whole it's a really good thing
there's two situations where
um you can have an increase in rates
uh one is when you've are putting in a
big
piece of infrastructure sayer um so
we're putting in a
big pump waste water pump station or
something and then you have to
you know you're taking out a loan on it
and funding it
um in most cases um that happens on big
schemes
like the likes of the eastern districts
or that's really where it
mostly happens and we can manage that
pretty pretty well just because of the
scale of it
with drainage particularly on the
smaller schemes
what tends to happen is we take on new
uh drainage infrastructure that has
attenuation and treatment facilities
in it and they do have an ongoing
maintenance cost even from day one
now the and you could end up in a
situation where the existing rate pays
their rates go up to start funding that
over the medium term that's again will
be to the benefit of the
um rate pairs because we've just been
busy getting our network discharge
consents for a stormwater
and they will start to over time require
additional works in existing parts of
town and when you've got the bigger
scheme
um now you've got more ratepayers that
will help fund that
so over the course of people's i suppose
life cycle within the
town they are probably better off having
those developments
connecting particularly given when
you're retrofitting stormwater treatment
into
existing areas it can be quite expensive
and you're not getting it gifted by a
developer
so look it's like all of our rates it's
not always exactly fair for any one
particular year
but overall the benefits are
generally uh felt by by the existing
rate payer because of development
okay any further questions all right
any general comments anyone would like
to make
thanks t so um sorry did i miss someone
okay
oh thank you stop water races were
included or is that in addition to
you dealing with that separately
page uh stopwater races 398-404
so no key issues with stock water apart
from
similar to drainage there is a change to
level of service as well so
i'll um i'll run that around while
answering any questions
i'll run the paper around not pay for it
well you're thinking all you need is a
good hitter dog and you'll be fine
thanks kelly thank you
oh
so
okay do you want to take us through
kelly thank you okay
so in terms of stock order there's no uh
key things to note there it's just got a
standard nominal
3.75 increase uh
in terms of the level of service
so there is a change in target
for um service requests within 48 hours
with the target of 95
so how do you take any questions okay
any questions
that's fairly clear oh council stuart
sorry
general one um wymac irrigation
administers the stock water system
maintains it for us
and also in conjunction does its own
irrigation scheme
we we pay them for that service
and um it's only relatively recently
that um
that i i think that the amount that is
paid to wyomik irrigation
for the maintenance and administration
of our stock water rate should actually
be made
public and it's not i don't i've never
seen it
in any of our budgets and um
i think it's last year we were we
renewed them and reviewed the contract
and
paid them more that's why we have the
charges we
have so your your question to staff is
if not why why why isn't that public
as part of this budget what we're paying
to a contractor
exclusive use of or
an exclusive service
the figure for race maintenance
is on page 403 um
so there's a figure there of 272
100. now that is
predominantly what we actually paid to
them but there is also
an allowance for um
additional charges
for things that come up operationally
throughout the year that aren't covered
by the agreement
so i believe the figure i don't know it
off the top of my head but it's
it's about twenty thousand dollars less
than that
okay any further questions cause of duty
council redmond uh
kelly on page 402
um maintenance of roadside stock water
races
you say if council were to take over
maintenance uh this would have a
significant impact
on stock water rates if the adjoining
land owners are happy to maintain
these areas if it's not broken do we
need to fix it
uh no we wouldn't uh
we're possible we would want the
existing
landowners to continue to maim the races
within the front of their property
there are a few locations with within
our district
such as along tram road where that type
of operation is
difficult for landowners to do safely
when it comes to all the traffic
management requirements
so our intention is we still see it as
being the most efficient way of doing it
is relying on
property owners to maintain the race um
and providing them advice on that
but we see more and more um with higher
health and safety and traffic management
requirements that
um there are going to potentially be
more races that we will need to
bring into being council maintained
sorry council blackie yes
page 402 kelly that that the
the planned not claim but the suggestion
of um
mar um we'll know more directly
feeding water race water into low end
streams
has any more thoughts and progress and
been done on that
from a stock water race perspective um
effectively what we're doing is just
monitoring the
overall length of our water races
enclosures and making sure that any
changes within the stock quarter a
system is not having
any um change in the aquifer recharge
that
that's occurring i'm aware that will
uh doing some work that's actually
looking at more
you know targeted or constructed managed
aquifer recharge systems
okay further questions any general
comments
okay thanks kelly um
now we'll come to jared's overheads so
it's pages 405 to 412.
thanks jared okay thank thank you
uh look i i i actually
um i think i'll just talk to the
um actual budget sheets on
pages four one one and four one two
because the commentaries
well the words are fine but the tables
and the commentary aren't really helpful
in
understanding just because of the format
so i'll start
in the um on page 411 the roading
section and just draw your attention to
the key numbers there
so you'll see the operation on the
operations line
just directly under the roading heading
in the annual plan in 2021 there's 309
000.
that was forecast to go to 315 and in
this budget it's three
sorry 462. so
um now that is the uh
result of the um roading
an additional position in the roading
team um
and we've called them the roading
strategy team leader
now i think we've i've discussed this on
a number of times with the council
um we're we're severely under-resourced
as a council in this
area and the key things are
things like developing our roading
strategies we've had
quite a change in focus from waka katahi
where we are not providing the same
level of resources our key
partners and particularly the city in
terms of this kind of an area
it's really critical in terms of
integrating with our
land use planning and development that
we've got
and also management of the capital works
program
so effectively a lot of the focus for
don young has been actually to try and
backfill
this role as much as possible and
otherwise it's being born by the roading
manager
and it's unsustainable so that's
been put into the budget we have um
discussed that with waka katahi and
we're expecting a positive response to
vehicle funding of
that position so um that's
that's something i hope i hope have i
have canvas pretty well
and hasn't come as a surprise to you um
the next one to look at
is in the three waters um
the key line there is again under
operations uh
you've got currently 1.05 million
was projected to go to 1.06 and
in the proposed ltp we've got 1.126
now that is for the asset analyst role
so there is some commentary on that
um i actually think jeff gave a really
good
example of the value um we can extract
out of a role like this um in his
presentation today where we were start
you know talking about the um confidence
that we have in our asset management
systems um without uh
you know the and we and we are doing a
lot of things but without someone in
three waters who's continuing to
get that information that we're going to
get out of our new amis system
put that into our asset management
practices we won't be able to keep
um up in that that kind of kind of
activity
so that's a pretty that again is a very
um a crucial
role for us and it's it's hard to
give you a tangible figure in terms of
the value um other than the sort of
uh those sorts of figures that um you're
looking at
this morning when you look at the total
value of those assets and the complexity
of the assets it's really important that
we've got a good understanding
of those when we're making far-reaching
decisions
now the third one i'll draw your
attention to is on page four one
two under land drainage
operations line again and you'll see um
it was projected at three points
sorry 370 000 um
and in the ltp we've got 409 in year one
but you'll notice in year two that goes
to 562.
so that is predominantly around
the um waterways and drainage
manager role and you'll recall that we
have
allocated some of our stimulus funding
for the
for the um front end of that position so
we are actually um trying to recruit
into that
role um and we've got it as part of our
signed off agreement for the
um stimulus funding 18 months worth of
funding and that's why you see it
phasing in
on those tables but the full effect that
we start to be felt from
22 23 for that role and that
um is that look that that role is to
just manage that expanding um area of
need
we've got a we've got a wastewater asset
manager we've got a water supply asset
manager but we definitely do have an
efficiency in that waterways and
drainage
area um and the uh
the demand keeps on growing in that area
um
from both up from operational um
and again from the compliance end of the
spectrum so look i'm
i'm happy to take any questions on on
these budgets otherwise other than those
three positions i've talked to the um
budgets are
pretty much just straight out as they as
they were previously
any questions counselor
is that the co-funded figure that's
correct that is
that's the full figure that's the full
figure with the co-funding
further questions any general comments
well jared because i'd like to commend
you particularly
of your the workload that you have
managed in this last
budget period has been immense both you
and
indirectly kelly as well i know kelly's
been putting in some unreal hours i've
heard
um i know all our staff are working hard
but in particular
i think you do an awesome job and we're
very lucky to have you in the role
you're you're performing you you manage
it so well
um and all the demands that you
get from elected members answering calls
at all hours of the day
and responding all hours of day too so
thank you i i think these extra amounts
are absolutely justified particularly
in the um area of of roading in
particular
and that extra support but we do need a
greater christchurch level because there
is just simply
a lot of work in the transport space so
that the extra support i will certainly
appreciate there because there's a lot
of we get
when we get meeting notice it's often
the papers don't come
out until quite short notice and that
extra support that i get to
be able to represent our council well is
appreciated so that helps in that
capacity that helps us keep projects
over the line the ones that we were
talking about earlier so
i fully support that but thanks for all
the work that you do in you too kelly
yeah thank you and i i'm just really
want to reinforce it's the
the people who working in the unr
department um
across the board particularly the
managers who report to me they
do some they do an incredible job thanks
thank you
all right pdu
okay kelly thank you
from one kelly to another thank you so
we're on page
um 413.
so we've got the pdu budgets as well as
um item 4.3 in the main agenda so happy
to take them in whichever order you
prefer
yeah it's a good idea
okay so you've got a paper first kelly
having a 4.3
okay budget first yeah yeah okay
budget sheets so pages 413.
thanks kelly thank you mr murray um so
the i suppose the key things with the
pdu
is that the this unit is a
self-funding unit so we don't take any
rates funding directly we
fund all of our costs
through the hourly charge rate that we
charge on capital works projects and we
adjust our staff levels to meet the
demands from our capital works and
renewals programs that
we undertake on behalf of our clients
there has been some change to our
budgets this year and some of that has
been
through the addition of two additional
roles within the civil projects
um budget area and
also there's been some small changes in
particular
in the development team budgets for
administration and subdivisional issues
and that's really just
based on the fact that we have had
some changes in our staff and those
budgets come from
a direct percentage of staff time so
when staff changes and salaries change
that
changes the budgets and that's why those
have
gone up from what has been predicted
our our hourly charge-out rates
will go up for the next financial year
although i have not
um finalized what those are going to be
yet but expect them to go up
nominally and um those that hourly
charge out rate not only covers our
costs but also
funds various work that the unit
undertakes including
acting as the procurement center of
excellence for the whole of the
organization
um and also covers quite a bit of the
development inquiries pre-application
meetings finish four level
inquiries and the work that pdu does in
that regard
so those are probably the key
areas that i wanted to point out to you
today
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you questions of course
kelly we had um balance to cameron
before christmas just remind me we
i think we requested a report from him
recently is that coming
yes to a future meeting yes yes that um
went through the management team
yesterday and is coming to the next
council meeting right thank you because
just chief double
that thank you any questions of kelly
either same applies with what i said
before
really appreciate your work kelly you
and the team it's um
you've been to a number of meetings
because you're under your amount of
scrutiny with development contributions
i'm always impressed with how you
how well you deal with that thank you
it's not an easy space to be in at times
uh and that but you you handle it really
well me and the team so thank you
okay so we with that we'll come to your
report
um 4.3 which is tab 5.
um so this report is the draft
development contribution schedules which
are based on the various um capital
works
budgets that are for growth so
the overall philosophy with the
development contributions
taken is that growth is self-funding
however it is important to note that
development contributions aren't the
only
costs that don't represent the only
infrastructure costs that are related
to developments it's often just the
trunk infrastructure that's included
with development contributions and
developers
do have to provide a lot of other
infrastructure that's not
covered through development
contributions
i suppose some key changes with this
year's schedules
is there are several new development
contribution areas for
new growth areas that we are looking to
service
in particular the outer east regular
which is that
inch farm as well
as some of the mixed-use business areas
in kaiapoi
and um the two two new
dc's are changed dc's as part of the
stimulus projects there
are also quite a number of projects that
have been added to the district routing
dc which have listed in the report and
so that has had an impact
on the district roading dc
as well um so have tried to summarize as
best i could uh
the reasons for all of the changes that
have happened
that have occurred to the various
development contributions and what the
impact of the dc's likely are for
developers in specific areas with total
dc's
ranging anywhere from about thirty
thousand up to
the mid fifties close to sixty thousand
dollars per lot in some of the
development areas
um so i am happy to take any questions
that you
have on the schedules
okay any questions
up here so so there's a recommendation
to my prepared to move moved by council
duty seconded by
councillor atkinson in the discussion
just following yeah yeah just just like
to say
kelly thank you very much you do a great
job and
um not always a rewarding job
from some clients but you do it great
so thank you very much
any further speakers i'll put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that caring thanks
kelly
so i think that's i think that's that's
you doing
well done jared who's next up
now chris
okay that's right
brief break why don't we just have
afternoon tea break now
and then we can just make sure simon's
ready for 350